american great microsoft could save the
day for tick-tock fans
it's in talks with the chinese owners of
the app to buy the service in the u.s
the deal could stave off a presidential
ban by ensuring
user data stays in the u.s
office life today would be unthinkable
without microsoft word
and excel but so far the world's leading
software producer hasn't ventured
significantly into social media
that however could change
president donald trump wants to ban
chinese-owned platform
tick-tock in the u.s he fears data from
u.s
citizens could end up in the hands of
beijing's communist party
this could be microsoft's chance
tick tock is an internationally
successful video platform
it allows users to upload short clips of
themselves and watch clips of others
available worldwide it is owned by a
chinese company
bite dance that's a problem for the us
government
trump wants to curb beijing's influence
in the united states
along with other chinese companies fight
dance is under pressure
tick-tock cannot stay in the current
format because it risks
sending back information on 100 million
americans
in china residents say they're surprised
that an app has been dragged into the
fight between politicians
i think it's because the u.s china
relationship has
really deteriorated recently
we use many apps and softwares that were
developed by the us
tiktok has been successful at gaining
many users around the world
but i didn't expect that due to
political reasons this could affect the
economy and even app users personally
so far microsoft's ventures into the
world of social media have been limited
to linkedin
a platform for career professionals but
this deal with tick tock
could give microsoft a larger market
share with younger millennials and
generation z
with pressure from the united states
government on tick tock
microsoft says it's looking to seal the
deal by september 15th
let's talk about that with chelsea
delaney so chelsea microsoft
reckons by buying up that business unit
it'll have control over users private
data
right now tick tock stores the data in
the us
its backup is in singapore what's going
to change
so this is really the big question is
who has control over
over this user data tick tock and its
parrot company say that
the user data of u.s users is safe that
they they store it in the u.s and they
have a backup in singapore
and they would not turn it over to
chinese authorities a lot of legal
experts in the u.s administration
say they don't really buy that because
chinese companies
generally have a mandate that if the
government asks for their data they do
have to turn it over
so uh this is obviously not just related
to tick tock it's it's become a much
bigger
security risk and in the united states
where the united states has a lot of
other company companies it's targeting
for for similar questions
is this quite a clever deal that
microsoft is
uh uh drawing up basically because i
mean
it's preempted this ban uh it foresees a
quite a clever business deal by saving
tick tock and tick tock fans at the same
time as expanding into social media
or could this all just terribly backfire
for microsoft
well for microsoft and also for the us
this is really
the best of both worlds because the u.s
really does
want tick tock to be in u.s hands they
want to be sure that the user data is
safe
it's also extremely extremely popular
right now it has about 100 million
users in the united states so the us
does want this to be bought by a u.s
company and for microsoft
this would obviously be just a massive
step into social media where they're not
really big right now
what's the stop microsoft handing over
data though to the chinese authorities i
mean they could do that just as well
under a certain pressure or if the
market segment is very important
for them in in china well i think under
this deal they would
they would buy the the us business so
they would not really have any
responsibility to
chinese authorities so i think that
this would certainly remove some of the
political risks
from the business could the tick tock
fad just as well
fizzle out if if a big huge company like
microsoft gets its hands on it well of
course and
we've seen this with many many other
social media companies if you remember
vine which was
hugely popular several years ago it's
very similar to tick tock short videos
it closed after it was bought by twitter
we also have seen you know snapchat
really have trouble
uh making a profit so it's not a
guarantee that if they do get bought by
microsoft that they'll be able to turn
this into some sort of profitable
business
okay we'll see what happens chelsea
delaney thank you very much for coming
in today and
giving us that insight